Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys are the like button, if you enjoy the video and yeah.
Let's begin. What's going on guys. This is.
Rob. It's been a while since we've done a beyond Omega level video.
And at long last, after countless requests.
Most of them coming from Erin Wilder, I'm finally giving.
In.
Let it never be said that I am not a benevolent ruler of the Rob core because
today on beyond Omega level, we're covering resurrection, man.
So without further ado, let's get into his origin.
So resurrection man was created by Dan Abnett, Andy landing and Jackson geese,
and first appeared and resurrection man, number one in 1997.
And according to his creators,
resurrection man was based on a Marvel character called Mr. Immortal,
who was a member of the great lakes. Avengers.
What is basically a comedy team filled with characters that their powers were
honestly kind of stupid, but as his name suggests, Mr. Mortals power was simple.
He was a mortal. He could be killed, but every time he died,
he'd be in voluntarily resurrected.
And that's basically it that's his only superpower.
He has no other extraordinary abilities whatsoever.
And so admin and landing realized that immortality on its own is a pretty
terrible superpower to have,
but it gave them an idea for a new character to create,
which is similar in concept to Mr. Immortal,
but with a twist that makes them less useless.
So resurrection man's real name is Mitch Shelly,
who was a lawyer in South Carolina that actually had mob connections because
everyone knows South Carolina is a hotspot for mafia activity. But anyway,
a group simply known as the lab used Mitch as an unwilling test subject for
technology, they were developing, known as tech tights,
which are basically microscopic nanobots that heal damaged cells.
The result of this experimentation was that Shelly lost his memory,
but gained the ability to resurrect himself upon his death.
The twist that admin Atlantic added to resurrection, man,
is that not only does he return to life every time he dies,
but each time he's resurrected,
he gains a new superpower that is related to the way he died.
Now we would learn a bit more about Mitch's true nature during his encounter
with a Phantom stranger, a being that's walked the earth from millennia, Noah,
Mitch. Isn't a comatose state.
He's approached by the Phantom stranger who tells him that the two of them have
worked together over the course of many lifetimes.
And that Mitch is one of his oldest friends suggesting that Mitch is much older
than we originally thought.
Now the Phantom stranger also reveals that in the past,
Mitch would not resurrect,
but instead be reincarnated as a completely new person and did not gain new
powers. Each time he died, as it turned out,
those abilities were given to him by the lab.
But before that Mitch was something much older.
And as he reaches out into the astral plane,
he recognizes the face of his longtime, nemesis Vandal Savage.
That's where the end of his first solo series.
It would be revealed that while the source of Mitch's mortality is unknown,
the lab gave him his power of instant resurrection and revolving superpowers was
working under the direction of Vandal Savage.
Now upon realizing he possesses the ability to resurrect with new powers,
Mitch wonders the earth,
trying to remember his identity and how he received his abilities.
One of the few things he remembers is that he was to fly,
which is something he finds out mere seconds before being shot by some gang
members executing a drive-by. Now Mitch also falls to his death,
but then wakes up to realize not only that he's alive,
but that now instead of flight,
he possesses the ability to manipulate the air around him into a hard construct
of sorts.
He uses this ability to stop an out-of-control semi as a Kareem's toward a diner
while trying to rescue the driver. The truck explodes killing him once again,
but then he reawakens this time assessing pyro Kinesis.
And so all those deaths and resurrections took place within just one issue was
erection man, number one, but in the next issue,
we see a good example of resurrection man's abilities in relation to some more
well-known DC characters, as he happens upon the justice league,
as they battle the super-villain amazing.
Who's a giant Android with the ability to mimic the powers of those.
He comes into contact with now,
the justice league have their hands full with the mezzo,
but resurrection man gets involved in the battle in order to help some
bystanders and also uses his pirate Kinesis to cauterize a wound suffered by the
flash. No, in the building that Mitch's in explodes. He dies once again,
but this time he comes back from the dead with the ability to create powerful
explosions, which he uses to blow amaze Ole apart, ending the battle.
And so this is an impressive feat as amazing had been too much for the combined
forces of the flash green lantern, Martian Manhunter wonder woman and Superman,
but even though it's impressive,
it does not really even come close to being Omega level.
And Michonne self says as much in the aftermath remarking that he isn't in the
same league as the heroes who are able to level cities and save millions while
he only has, as he describes it, budget superpowers.
So he has like the scifi channel version of superpowers right now later,
Mitch would encounter Tommy Monahan, better known as Hitman,
who decides that he's going to help Mitch take on the lab by killing him
repeatedly until he gets a power that's strong enough upon his resurrection.
We really need to cover this guy's stories.
Now after several attempts where Mitch comes back to life with the ability to
create colorful butterflies made of light or change colors, like a chameleon,
Hitman is finally satisfied when Mitch gains the ability to manipulate cosmic
energy, along with a sort of cosmic awareness.
Now it could be argued that resurrection man was bordering on Omega level at
this point,
as he seemed to be able to manipulate both energy and matter on an atomic level.
And this shows us why we can consider resurrection man, uh,
beyond Omega level character,
because at any time he could be killed and come back to life with any power,
including those that would make him a planetary or universal threat.
The problem is he rarely keeps those powers for very long and he dies a lot
because dying and coming back to life with different powers is kind of what
makes his character interesting.
Now there would be other instances where resurrection man could be at or near
Omega level as well,
such as the time he was subjected to the reality warping abilities of a villain
known as schism,
which resulted in him dying and gaining what he calls quantum telekinesis,
which in practice seems to be a form of reality. Warping. In fact,
miss describes this ability by saying that he feels like he can do anything he
wants. And Superman describes his power as reality warping,
which leads him to find you as a wretched man and bringing him in to help the
justice league defeat a villain called major force,
who I believe was the same guy that stuffed Kyle Rainer's girlfriend in a
refrigerator. The guy was kind of a Dick now Mitch helps them,
but ultimately decides not to join the justice league saying that the superhero
life was simply not for him. And so over the course of his history,
resurrection man has had a variety of powers and it would really take too long
to list them here. But everything from super strength to energy absorption,
to super speed, to shape-shifting to oblate blast, if it's a superpower,
you can think of he's probably had it,
but what makes him potentially beyond Omega level or at least definitely beyond
Omega level is the possibility that at any time he could resurrect with a power
that has devastating potential.
And that happened on a couple of occasions when he gained a matter of
manipulation and reality warping powers in the DC 1 million mini series,
a possible future was revealed where Mitch had a device known as the resurrector
that allowed him to choose the power he would have upon his resurrection.
And in that instance,
he could definitely be a beyond Omega level character as he could grant himself,
all those powers at any point in time,
keep in mind that it's not considered in continuity,
but should it ever come to pass?
Whereas erection man would become one of the most powerful characters in DC
comics on a permanent basis, instead of only for short stints,
when he possessed matter of manipulation and reality warping before being killed
again. Oh, that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end,
Aaron Wilder. I hope you're happy that you got a video on resurrection, Mattamy.
God knows you actually got a whole ton of members of the Rob force to rally to
your side. Right?
Like it was kind of funny cause I was always wondering how long this was going
to go on for. And like literally it wasn't,
it stopped being just you asking for resurrection man.
And it started being groups of people, right?
Like whole groups of people who were like, don't worry, Aaron Wilder.
We're going to get robbed to do a video on resurrection, man.
So I hope you're happy that you have it.
You managed to rally the wrong court to your side.
And so I have done it for real, for true though.
It wasn't that I was ignoring you. It was just,
I get so many different requests. It's really hard to, hard to fulfill them all.
So, ah, here you go, man. Your video resurrection, man. I hope you enjoyed it.
I have no doubt that Aaron Wilder is going to ask for more stuff.
You guys always do. I literally had a guy who did that, right.
He asked for a beyond Omega level video. I made a comment.
He was probably going to ask for more stuff and he did so, uh,
as always hosted requests down below in the comments section.
But if you guys are new here to comments,
explain to make sure you guys are the sub button to become part of the rod pork.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a like,
and I will catch you all later.
[Inaudible]
[inaudible].